jamais j'aurais crise à la main je me
serais dit de carla ou dans la vie à 30
ans jouant sur fès le coin d'une rue
très accords et pour ma prochaine
d'autres stéphanie à 29 ans aujourd'hui
elles habitent laval élevé des fruits de
la prostitution depuis près de quinze
ans elle a bien voulu nous rencontrer
dans son petit havre de paix un des
rares endroits où elles se sont bien
tenues ce coin de rue à attendre après
un trou de cul pour aller rien il ya
rien de galicia la douleur elle consomme
en moyenne pour 275 $ de crack par jour
son proxénète la tient par son point
faible juil aps haut en ce moment moi
j'ai surgi à la consommation j'aime mon
pays c'est ma drogue problème c'est mon
vendeur à 12 ans en plein début
d'adolescence
elle vit entre les centres d'accueil et
le folie familiale qu'elle a voulu fuir
à tout prix besoin d'un break de mes
parents j'ai jamais dit pourquoi non non
non je vais pas faire la fête
le temps passe c'est sa mère qui lui
propose aller vivre avec elle à montréal
elle a maintenant 15 ans et c'est là que
ça dérape pas ta maman travaille de nuit
dans un salon de massage érotique comme
les sectionnistes rencontre un noir ça a
commencé comme ça qu'est ce que
commencer ben la drogue la prostitution
et c'est gratuit c'est tranquillement
pas lui qui deviennent des ennemis et
après ça on est bien jeune bien naïve le
piège venait de se refermer
il faudra plusieurs années avant qu'elle
aboutisse à laval tentant de fuir
c'est des moments real et c'est sûr que
la personne qui est intoxiqué tant
qu'elle est passable pour laisser les
problèmes de son enfance et problème de
son adolescence à laval le problème de
la prostitution n'est pas nouveau
frédéric jean qui a été patrouilleurs de
nuit pendant 14 ans connaît bien le
problème que vit stéphanie malgré les
difficultés il entretient toujours un
espoir pour l'avoir rencontrée je pense
que allait déjà prises je fais des
étapes ou est ce qu'elle est une prise
de conscience de sa problématique mais
c'est un équilibre qui est toujours
fragile ces gens là c'est sûr que c'est
valorisant de les voir transformer mais
faut pas oublier que pour chacun d'entre
eux il ya aussi des jets qui ont jamais
vécu cette transformation aulas ils sont
décédés fixée pour ce groupe opère des
sports jamais mon expérience je peux
passer par là je viens d'en faire un
beau cadeau à lévis
gm de femmes on est pas pour essayer de
m'en sortir moi même je fais pas juste
pour moi mais je fais aussi pour paul à
dire que cela existe pour bien des
jeunes filles
cet escalier représente la seule chance
de survivre
des organismes comme l'oasis à laval les
accompagnent stéphanie et a rencontré
jeanne elles sont devenus complices
moi ce que j'espère le plus c'est d'être
cette personne-là la personne à qui avec
qui justement alors un lien qui vont
faire la différence quand à wade s'en
sortir d'aller travailler si on lui
donnait des condoms donc notre mandat
nous c'est pas d'empêcher les gens de
face qui font ces coûts de leur fournir
les informations plus matériels qui ont
besoin pour rester le plus longtemps
possible
il faut jouer à arrêter de consommer
jour là mais c'est impossible à mon cas
à moi mais je fais des efforts à tous
les jours pourrait diminuer ma
consommation paraît un jour je reçois ma
laissé se sait se sait pas comment fin
j'ai pu j'ai pas les agresser mais je
travaille travaille